this is just that to me like this this
is like the most up and down
relationship yeah
like that is what it's like with having
Henry Cavill is Superman
[Music]
what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we have some major DC
updates here that are coming from The
Hollywood Reporter something a little
bit more reliable than your average
scooper out there ladies and gentlemen
leave a like because that's just always
a nice thing to do we need nice things
in this world John who are you I'm good
sir how are you good you rush to get
your Batman shirt how was that going
it's so good I love this Batman once I
said we're doing DC Video
I'm running to my car to get my Batman
shirt yeah all right man on top of it
here's the nuts and bolts version of
what's going on right now I'm gonna
quote Jeff Snyder here who's becoming a
popular scooper himself but this is
pretty much the nuts and bolts version
Wonder Woman 3 is dead that's right Gal
Gadot passed away
terrible things are happening can't even
get Linda Carter yeah the basic version
of it is that they probably turn into a
treatment for this uh movie that you
know Patty Jenkins was hard at work but
it doesn't quite line up with what they
have in store for the future of the DCU
I find that kind of a bummer because
Wonder Woman I think is a amazing film
and while wasn't a fan of 84 I really
felt like it still deserved a part three
and for them to go out on a high note
doesn't mean it's I don't know if it's a
little misleading to say it's dead but
the impression of this article that I
quickly read through the current
possible plan because James Gunn is
supposed to present like a whole thing
with him and saffron present a whole
thing to David zasloff of what the plan
is so nothing's like concrete at the
moment it sounds like they want to just
essentially do a big reset on the entire
thing but keep this Suicide Squad 52 but
yes I want my movie still around yeah
that's not in the article John how do
you feel about Wonder Woman three
possibly being dead I mean it's like it
is yeah it's absolutely a bum myrrh
because that is like one of their more
reliable even though 84 wasn't well
received it's one of their more Flagship
characters one that most people agree on
at least in terms of the casting and a
lot of the portrayal thus far I don't
know I mean if they're truly resetting
that's a pretty big bummer at the same
time I get them wanting to reset I just
feel like it'll be hard for people to
swallow if it's not Gal Gadot some way
don't worry we got Black Adam and
Superman used to get to Boom Black Adam
sequel looking unlikely apparently so
there's been a lot of debate here about
whether or not Black Adam was a success
or was it a big box office bomb I
expected it to break even is it even
gonna do that there's been reports that
it's certainly a bomb but then Dwayne
Johnson he came out uh four hours ago up
from recording this video I wanted to
confirm with financiers before I share
this excellent Black Adam news with your
films we'll profit between 52 to 72
million fact at almost 400 million
worldwide we are building our new
franchise step by step first Captain
America did 370 million for the DC
future I don't know the exact intention
of Dwayne Johnson doing this maybe to
shut down all those things that are
saying that's going to flop or maybe it
is having something to do with the fact
that he's worried that he might not get
the future films like guys it's actually
did all right because don't forget cap
the first Captain America
so come on
to push it along a little further yes
they need to spend more money on it next
time I wouldn't be surprised if they
don't get a sequel because I mean 52 to
72 Millions like that's a that's a good
amount of money to make but they didn't
spend a lot of money to try to get that
52 to 72 million they only made enough
to make a mid budget indie film they
need that Blockbuster profit because one
of the second one cost more money
theoretically let's mix Black Adam 2 a
very introspective one location movie
yeah and he was talking about doing a
Hawkman spin-off but I don't know that
if they're gonna be a Black Adam too I
mean I don't think we get a Hawkman
spin-off here's the big one here's the
kicker after all that stuff about Henry
Cavill coming back into the the fold to
play Superman Man of Steel Henry Cavill
himself even going on Instagram saying I
am back to Superman he's doing his best
Dwayne Johnson impression it's being
reported now because it looks like what
they're trying to do is do as much of a
reason that means even putting the
Snyder verse to rest and so you know
they've they filmed the Cameo as
Superman for the flash but it's still up
in the air whether or not they want to
actually include it depending on the
plan that they set forward for the
future of the DC Universe
this is just that to me like this this
is like the most up and down
relationship yeah
like that is what it's like with having
Henry Cavill is Superman yeah it's well
that and it's too it's like living in a
house where like your parents are
constantly like almost about to make it
work and get back together or something
too because now it's like no no no we
bought it we brought in James gun we got
we got Peter saffron it's gonna be great
it's gonna be great except we're also
giving them like a whole train wreck of
a Segway that I can't imagine is gonna
rub everybody the right way it just
seems like nobody is getting the full
kind of I don't know conscientious
treatment here well I think if they want
to move forward they have to have a
fresh start but keep the suicide squad
alive that's right Squad
they still haven't even presented their
entire plan yet and I imagine they'd
want to preserve some of this like I
don't I I don't feel like you can just
confidently go ahead and come do a
complete reset I think that is not a way
of listening to the fans ultimately you
know yeah but if it is what's best for
the long term maybe perhaps like I at
this point why not try everything out DC
just just do it all cancel it all then
bring it all back later yeah you can
always ignore whatever you do now and
come back to the Snyder verse later I
don't care anymore just make it happen
the next order of business Aquaman 2
might be the last time we see Jason
Momoa playing Arthur Curry Aquaman
himself but as we saw like Jason Mo not
long ago doing a video like I got some
exciting [ __ ] to announce to you guys
but I can't say that what it is whatever
he said in that video a lot of people
are speculating and it seems like it
would be likely based off of what his
enthusiasm was is that he would he's
being eyed to possibly play Lobo which
is a character he he's the perfect guy
and he's a man massive fan of that
character strangely enough as much as I
really like him as Aquaman I'm also like
out of all the news strangely on board
for that one all these random train
wrecks but then the perfect dream
casting
all right it aren't you happy it's not
Michael Bay slope yeah even though
Aquaman one made a billion dollars it's
just a little bit uh strange to me that
out of all the news that's the one that
I'm like yeah I'm on board with that
that's fine we had enough Aquaman and
then you know Batman's still gonna
persevere but you still got Shazam for
you the Gods coming out you still got
Blue Beetle you still got the Flash
movie releasing it's like at this point
you're like if you're just gonna erase
it all what's the point of even
releasing them yeah I was just gonna
confuse people that much more at least
the general populace who's not following
this news very closely but yeah as of
this report it's like Henry Cavill not
coming back again basically Wonder Woman
three dead all that stuff you were just
excited about not anymore and
um I I just I don't know anymore I I
don't know at this point I'm like before
before we get up in arms about every
little thing I was like let's just wait
to see what James could actually believe
what's presented yeah first like the one
that seems most likely to me is what
happened Wonder Woman three but
everything else is kind of speculation
and scoop talking and everything it's
all true it's all true let's just
believe it all let's believe it all I'll
believe nothing until I see the movie on
the screen alrighty well there we are
guys what do you think which person is
here's the the elicited the biggest
reaction out of you all uh leave your
thoughts down below I'm just exhausted
I'm sorry all the DC fans just need a
hug this is supposed to be like the
biggest thing ever now it's like ah
Christ I don't know what to believe so
let's just wait for official stuff I
suppose alrighty
Everett pixel might Baker Everett we
might not know anything about you
I don't know anything about you we can
make it up you can you can we can
project onto you everything you've been
a patron of ours for four years
that's incredible I don't really know
much about it you are dedicated and
unlike the DC Universe you've been a
constant that's around your life you
have to worry about you being recast we
don't have to worry about you coming and
going whether or not Everett's going to
stay or leave Everett is the picture of
consistency I think what James Gunn
needs to do moving forward Everett is
take a page out of every pixel my bakery
what can we learn from every pixel my
Baker As we move forward with the DC
Universe we Comfort people with the warm
embrace of consistent and jovial caring
love so thank you Everett for always
being a monthly Christmas present to us
and I hope you have an amazing amazing
2023 filled with laughter love and lots
of play time
with men and women
[Music]